we post this on
discord wait for a few people to get in
here and then we will start our office
tour
give everyone a few minutes to get in
here
i take a little bit of spin drift no
more leaks bros no more leaks
i'm so happy you know i'm so sad when
we're uh
when we have secrets i hate secrets i
hate keeping secrets
it's like lying i hate lying
uh so we don't have any more secrets
we're here to show you everything
come to production let's wait for a few
more people uh to get in here
and then we'll go for uh an office tour
wow there really are no more secrets
like i can show you guys the board
uh i can show you all everything
oops all right cool 44. let's get to
100.
let's get to 100 and then we'll uh we'll
uh we'll walk around the uh
the office
we've been working on the common three
for like three years now
uh all right let's go
so here we are this is all the comma
three boxes
wow that's a lot of boxes oh yeah look
oh we got more boxes over here
oh more boxes over here these are where
all the cases come from
this is what they look like before
they're sandblasted kind of gross
that's why we sandblast them uh this is
the heat sinks that still need to go
through final finishing
uh oh i guess we did get some knight
giraffes back from the jeopardy prize
look at these boxes look at these boxes
everywhere everywhere
um driver monitoring metrics uh
we've improved low light
face detected comma 3 a lot
these are on new priorities now
uh yeah office is up there open pilot
1.0 you guys have seen that before
accessory boxes foam inserts
so much stuff this is the lens focusing
room
[Music]
come with three cameras being focused
continuous positive air pressure
so that we don't uh awesome it's so nice
to show everybody everything now yeah
yeah so nice no more secrets no more
secrets
yeah you want to talk about what you're
doing i'm fixing the focusing setup
uh so this is the sound we use for
focusing on the lenses
now it's set up to focus the wide-angle
one so it's pretty short range for the
third monitoring
we also have these mirrors to simulate
like a longer distance from
the narrow angle cameras yeah i wish i
could use the mirrors for filming
we've got quality quality focus pattern
over there is that really what we're no
no we're
have you guys seen a virtual eye test
it's very similar to that
um these cameras are bad
oh but yeah wow that's that looks so
professional
listen these we've gotten here
oh more camera boards
yeah i'll see what we got
infrastructure room the remnants of all
the failed
la ecos from the comma twos
uh what else we got
the remnants of the donuts from
comic-con
these are some comma threes being tested
you see that like we're catching
failures i think this one doesn't have a
camera plugged in great
um
still we have a card out here comma twos
these got to go away
some new comma threes for final
provisioning
all of various failures
um a beautiful set of comma three boards
just getting their psalms
and all this stuff's cool
some lenses of various sizes
injection molded fronts
oh you feel that the biggest holding
back in self-driving cars is software
not hardware well i mean that's
definitely true but uh
better hardware helps a bit we don't
want to disrupt the production people
too much we want to get you guys your
commentaries
as soon as possible got some boxes ready
to go
check out that beautiful cross country
edition logo
um
you want to say hi to the stream hi
i have a lot to do today yeah it's nice
to not have secrets anymore
it's so weird tonight of secrets you
know what are the secrets that's not
secrets
guys we're we're planning a comma 3s
like in like two years
is it feasible to do some model training
on the comma threes no
comma three circuit boards you wanna
show them anything nick
[Music]
like a secret anymore like some of the
later this is the new camera that's in
progress for the comma threes
it doesn't have any difference for you
the functionality of it's identical
but we're using these rigid flex boards
so there's one less wire that people
have to plug in
lowers assembly costs
yeah what else is there anything oh
should we show them like old wrap oh
yeah
see these these are the the old crappy
revs of the common threes this one was
so crappy that they didn't even cut out
the hole for the dm camera
we fixed that on ref c and then we
realized that it looked disgusting
so we went to the uh non-square dm
camera
that you see now on the rev h's which
are the ones we're shipping
um calendar yeah yeah this is
the plans now batch one batch two
no secrets that's so nice i hate having
secrets all these are some so we got
more songs
guys you know almost all this stuff
costs an outlier
tons what are those
oh in doctors
are we using solder wick at scale yeah
we gotta buy it we gotta buy the world
supply
uh whenever igor gets back he wants to
show off the red pandas
we're gonna build our first bunch of red
pandas
uh we don't have a trade-in program
unfortunately uh
guys we're not apple i can't do
everything at that sort of scale
um but you know you guys can just bite
you want
oh
red pandas that's the whole box full i
think
these are all red pandas let's say oh
yeah look
individually wrapped red pandas
we went with a different manufacturing
company for these
uh yeah lots of red pandas
you know every comma three has an nfc
tag in it
it's one of these nfc tags
old revisions yeah failures failures
that's one of the common dudes that blew
up when removing the battery exploded
this comma two that was left in a
ultrasonic cleaner for three weeks
oops accidentally
yeah solder paste stencils
yeah different oh yeah this is when we
were
moving each individual hole on the back
of the comma three
oh you mean the original comma three
that became the sex well that
yeah or just the
the bend beam flex right board oh that's
the bend yeah
yeah is this the hardware museum yeah
yeah
yeah the museum vip office two or five
grand let's put on
this site
hey chris you got anything to say to the
streams oh what's up everybody
you want to show them anything this is a
board what's wrong with it oh this is a
old board that's got some
issues but what rev is it it's a rev
it's the one we're shook oh it's h
check it out yeah we didn't we we didn't
write h on it i don't know what we were
thinking we should have wrote it
right we were like we'll delete the ref
because this is the final one forever
and then like well you know
[Laughter]
no there's no known bugs with h
that's why it's the one we're shipping
they were known bugs with every rav4
that's why we didn't ship those it's
kind of why it took so long
uh where's the not the data center it's
over there
yeah oh it's so nice to not have secrets
we've got red pandas we're going to ship
them out soon we've got to work on some
testing for them
can fd plugs into your comma 3.
uh the version numbers became something
different we had one schedule for the
version numbers and then we switched it
but the comma two will be left with
something good you can see our neon
cameras over uh
commas over here uh yeah
that was just so much it's all gotta go
away somewhere
foam pouches i don't even know what we
do with those
this is what happens when you put a
common three box together backwards
we ship them all black so it's stealth
uh i don't even have a comma three in my
office everyone took my comma threes
hey look it's our youtube video
oh is the traffic light the traffic
light represents the ci tests
uh so you can see that it's green right
now because all the tests are good
uh here's lunch you guys want some ribs
ribs are pretty good
[Music]
uh do a reaction to the live stream who
am i bo burnham
we're not going to disturb the research
office they have important research to
do they're out working on your
longitudinal
um
uh yeah uh
yo guys should i show the shopify
numbers they're really good
we rich boys we rich um
we're rich we rich we rich
ah uh we needed to make three hundred
thousand dollars this weekend
or you know we were gonna have to raise
money uh we
uh blew away the target of 300 thousand
dollars we now have
extra money i love having extra money
you see what good mood i'm in when we
have money i'm in a good mood you know
um no i don't even have a combo all i
have is a combat too i don't even have a
comma three in my office who took my
comma three i don't know where it went
concrete very rare it's probably
shipping uh
numbers nah no numbers no numbers it's
not yet o'clock yet
but we were talking about transitioning
the company 100
off of shitty spinning discs and over to
ssds
we can now afford ssds uh by how much
did we overshoot our goal
big money no not that much but enough
that we feel very comfortable
uh yeah
watching live in temecula cool brevin it
was great having brevin was great having
you there
thank you for manning the comet 3 booth
um
that's it that's kind of all i got you
guys saw the cool stuff that lens
focusing rigs real cool
uh why don't we combine it into a
hand-engineered perception layer
yeah hitting your perception layer yeah
gross we do want to end here
yeah we need a new office if anyone
knows a good office we want an office
around san diego area i share my
injection molding per unit price
yeah the molds themselves aren't that
expensive i think we're only paying like
like eight bucks for the case uh
but getting the molds made costs a lot
of money getting the molds
fixed costs a lot of money and then we
have to hand individually sandblast them
so that
uh i didn't even go to the top see there
wasn't it there was an after party i
didn't even go
uh i went home i was tired are you still
streaming
yeah yeah yeah we got them for sale tell
them if they buy one during your stream
wait we are we pumping right now alex
this is adding complexity to shipping
oh there's just too much complexity for
shipping all right i'll show you guys
which ones
these are ultra rare there's a few left
these are no
i think we keep them okay you want to
keep them what do you want what do you
want to do with them
i don't have any preference i was just
coming i was just cleaning my office and
i found them
um three comma hat
says comma on the back this is that
screen
comma join the three comma club my
head's too big
well a lot everyone knows that
no no it's too hard if we like to like
say like we're gonna ship some you know
all right
i'll put one on the website for one for
500 bucks
it's the last though well how many we
have left there's four
yeah i think i think um i don't know
what's a good price for the hats what's
a good price for the hats guys
gift whoa that's not a good price
1k oh wow that's really what they're
saying
420 i like that 420 salt no no
69.69 is good we did that ones with
beanies we sold 69
beanies yeah we still do we sell 675 oh
sick
can i keep this hotties can i keep this
one
and we have to sell salad you didn't
sick bro you look like a real bro with
that on
yeah yeah yeah you guys want to go uh
you know anyone got a keg bro
anyone got a keg i'm interested in a keg
wait never mind employees didn't get
them you can't buy them
can't buy them yo check out the three
common hat though this is the official
hat of the comma three
that was better
all right boys um yo if you're out there
from the media
uh send me an email i'm happy to do uh
tell you guys about the comma three we
have a press kit ready
we have a press release coming out
tomorrow when everyone has free time
again
uh all the lane changing possible yes if
your car has
uh good blind spot monitors but it's not
high on the priority list
very low on the priority list am i going
to participate in advent code this year
only if i'm having a good time if i
start to not have a good time i'm not
going to play i had a very good time the
first year
second year no i still had a good time
it'll be chill it'll be chill
you know i can't beat myself uh up if
you know it's like oh you got to be
there it's like no man i got things to
do all the way up
in a coat you know we only do it if
we're here to party right
when does the consumer version get
released
long ass time um so we were on the comma
2 platform effectively the comma 2
platform for like four years
we think the same thing is gonna be true
for the comma three platform so the
comma two platform included
the uh eon the neo the eon gold
and the uh comma two
how can you request a press kit are you
press press at comma ai
you must be legitimate press
for a
long time you want an ipo release
yeah gross stop making money off the
backs of others
that's what losers do start making money
off your own back start creating value
in the world
is then your immediately noticeable
difference between the c2 and c3
the beautiful oled display uh
the stunning crispy picture crispy hdr
picture
uh yeah
cool no we'll send it to vloggers i'm
just playing
email press to come today i'll send you
the top
uh yeah no we have to use the integrator
radar system if we want to see the blind
spots uh and also to see if cars are
coming up fast so you need cars with
good blind spot monitors
part of the reason we made the red panda
is it puts can fd and some of the blind
spot monitors are on can fd
um your c2 demo window closed
two weeks ago are you no
the return of two weeks ago could i have
three weeks ago now guys we're either
a company of laws or we have nothing
right
is the model open source uh yes uh the
training code's not
uh the training code would only be
useful to you if you had a half million
dollar supercomputer and the only people
with that are evil corporations
um so that's why the training code is
not open source but the model itself is
open source it's mg license just like
everything else
people are like common used to open
source their model architecture well we
did you just didn't look very hard it's
an onyx file bro it's the most common
shared model format there is
just go into models and you know dump
the onyx file load it into whatever you
can run it on a pc you can run a comma
two and you can run another command
three
can you sleep while commas being used no
um
is there a panda inside the c3 like c2
yes uh the panda inside the comma three
is called the
dos and the panda inside the comma two
is called the uno
all right any other good questions
uh we don't ship from the netherlands we
don't ship from europe the europe office
is just a software development
contractor we do not do any hardware out
of the europe office uh
you're going to deal with those
regulations you know um
has an oled display should i be worried
about burning we can want to go to the
testing closet i can show you the ones
we've had up for weeks there's no real
burning
so that's all i can really say about
that like we did test for it they seem
pretty good
they're samsung they're samsung oleds
like they're nice oleds
um so yeah if you like keep up one
graphic on there for a long time but
open pilot should never do that
uh
the 360 view will require neural network
retraining we need you all to buy comma
threes
we need you all to buy comma threes so
you can give us the data so we can
improve your comma threes
and you guys know if you're one of the
first people to give us data
you're going to probably be included in
the network forever
uh you ordered your cross-country
edition yesterday do i think it'll ship
this week
maybe if not this week then early next
again i can't make any promises uh
but maybe soon
you're definitely i promise i can make
this promise we are going to ship
out every cross-country edition before
we start shipping out the other ones
uh so you know it should comfortably be
in two weeks
when will vws and audi be supported they
are
uh how can i buy 35 of your company you
actually can't
you can buy every available share of
comment and it's still not 35
i'm not selling you [ __ ] um
can you buy a commentary and put in a
zip car i don't know how zip cars work
you probably put it on uber and put it
in some
put it in turo i mean that'd be great
someone should put an atturo i'd show
you on twitter
if somebody gets a turo car and puts a
comment in it i tell people on tara
you can't buy comma shares we're not a
financial instrument we're a company
that creates something
um no upgrade program sorry you want an
upgrade program go on for sale sell you
two coin buy three coin
uh that's all i can really say about
that um also actually even better
sell your comment two to a friend uh
sell your comment
to a neighbor sell your computer to
somebody with a supported car uh
like just because the comma three's out
it doesn't take away from the comma two
the comma two is still great
now you wanna work there that's a whole
different thing we're definitely hiring
um if you have the right sort of skills
uh we'd love to hire you uh if you're
interested in research we have a
research challenge if you're interested
in an open pilot team the best way to
get hired for open pilot team is to
start contributing to open pilot
i wouldn't say that uh will new features
become the number two yeah
some will some will some will be three
exclusive look
if there's a new feature if we develop a
new feature i'm not gonna like be a dick
and write an if statement and be like if
comma three work else don't right like
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna be a dick
if there's a feature and it's like well
it would be an extra couple weeks of
work to make it work on the two well
then it's gonna be three only
um but like a lot of the longitudinal
improvements are just gonna come to both
can you contribute to the open source of
html and css skills well
open pilot is written in c plus and
python so those are the skills you need
do we offer employee stock options
absolutely yeah um being an employee
here is one of the only ways to get
comma stock
uh or to buy it from an employee uh or
next employee
uh yeah so that's like you know who owns
who owns the company the people who
create the value right and then once
they you know create the value of course
when you're an employee uh you have
stock options
you can access there's a one-year cliff
but once you uh own the options you can
exercise the options at any time
and there's no we have no transfer
restrictions uh so this is another thing
that was an important
thing to me i hate those companies that
do the uh like oh well you have a lock
up
period for your ship we don't have
anything like that if you work here
you get stock you can sell your stock
is burning covered by the warranty um
what do tvs do for this uh what are
phones though
i think i think we'll do the same thing
uh like i said i haven't really seen it
be a problem and if we start to see if
anyone starts to show signs of burn in
we'll fix it in the in the ui but i i
don't think
i don't think the oleds really burn in
um so no if you run some weird thing and
get burning no of course that's not
covered by the warranty
but if you're running normal open pilot
using it normally it shouldn't burn in
and if it is
we'll really look into it um
would you guys rather an lcd do an lcd
ah
we are a private company uh does the
better vision of the common three result
and better performance like it chiming
less about distraction when the driver
is not distracted
if you're having that happening do you
upload the front camera if you upload
the front camera and you're getting
false positives for driver monitoring
we'll look into those right away that
shouldn't happen
um in for a devops yeah we hire for that
absolutely
uh he wanted it for devops job
yeah just just just reach in i think i
think that will go through like the
hackerrank pipeline
um
if you make it through the hackarack
pipeline you'll hear from greg
you'll hear from me i'll ask you a bunch
of questions you know know about you
gotta know a lot about computers and
like how this all works
and we're gonna go all across the stack
uh so if you like
learned if you memorize like one set of
certain skill like i know this cloud
platform
you probably won't get hired for infra
here but if you know everything from
like
you know okay if i tell you in a
motherboard like um
you know uh tell me about how pcie is
connected to the cpu right like i'm
interested in things like that
all the way up to like tell me how dma
works tell me what a kernel is tell me
what a sys call is
right all the way up um so another whole
stack
longitudinal control come to the comma
three on the honda accord i'll do you
one better
uh that's one of the features that's
platform agnostic so if it comes to
three it'll come to the tip
the main the big push now for the three
is going to be on uh the navigation
stuff
and then you're gonna get just some
passive benefits by the camera being
better
um and you're also gonna get some
passive benefits by the cpu being better
it's nice to have an eight core cpu
instead of a four core cpu
how many pull requests in open pile to
get hired for an internship if you're
thinking like that it's not for you
right if you're thinking of mentality
like i'm gonna like check x boxes
if you create value for the open pilot
repo i'd happily give you an internship
right that's the right mentality
um
well support stop for eon gold same as
the same as the com2
the eon gold and the black panda and the
comma two are effectively the same
um we stopped support for the original
eon because it required us to maintain
kernel patches
as we started to dive deep into the
kernel we wanted to make sure we were
delivering a uniform experience we
offered
everybody a free trade-in from their
original eon to the eon gold
um assuming that they bought it from us
so uh yeah you know and
people like oh you deprecated the gray
panda yeah but we offered everybody a
full money back we offered people a 200
discount
if they sent in a great panda which was
the full price they paid for a gray
panda
we're pretty good when we deprecate
hardware i don't know what like the hate
on reddit is about this i think there's
just like
two haters about there who are just
looking for things to hate it's like
you know we're pretty decent about about
uh hardware
uh lifecycles uh how are we gonna manage
the different stacks it's unified go and
master right now
uh master on the open pilot repo now
supports both the comma two and the
comma three and ninety five percent of
the code is the same
we have good hardware abstraction layers
for all the stuff
uh no discount for the comment too the
price is the same buy a good one
um you know you missed the trade-in pay
attention i mean i don't know what to
tell you about that
um with the comment three cross-country
can you connect it to the computer and
access videos in the ssd yeah of course
i mean you could like it has wi-fi you
can do it over wi-fi can you do it over
the usb port actually
you know what you can do get a usb to
ethernet
uh again get one of these uh you can
plug this into the expansion port on
your comma three
and it'll just be on your internet with
gigabit you could say the files off
uh did i really name the company after
smoking pot and silicon valley on hbo
yes absolutely
um names are mostly stupid
uh
will comment three work for cars in
pakistan see why not
like my thing about countries it's like
i don't know we train on whatever data
we get
if there's a bunch of people in pakistan
using them they'll have data and growth
maybe look similar enough to everywhere
else it'd probably work
um who designed the logo
i think i did the original one
uh longitudinal for honda accord being
worked on uh
yeah yeah yeah working on that um
i want to support the f150 what's the
worst mistake comment ever made
shiffer uh yeah we made a phone app it
was kind of uh
you know the comma six was also a big
mistake we made a few mistakes they
weren't like huge huge but
um schiffer turned out to be just
completely not necessary and the comma
six
nvidia turned out to you know uh
when leadership changes make sure your
deals are iron clad in writing
do i regret the name of decision.com is
a sick name uh
have we been approached by oems yeah a
whole lot but the problem is they don't
really know how to approach us right
like i'm not interested in
some shitty development deal like if an
oem approaches us i'm like okay how many
comma threes you want to buy we'll sell
you a bulk discount
i'll even put it in a different box if
you buy enough you want you want a
little one in a silver box you can snap
in your little thingy i'll do that for
you
you know send me 10 million dollars for
uh you know 5 000 of them and we're done
sold um yeah
so but no this isn't how the automakers
work they want this ridiculous stuff and
like
you know it's not like i said it's not
going to be ford buying comma it's going
to be comma buying ford
uh how can somebody ask me for a youtube
interview
uh i'll likely only do it if you have a
good chance at a million views
um maybe you can have an email and ask
if you if you have a channel that has
like a bunch of million view videos i'm
probably interested but
um
android auto compatibility not
officially again it's something that's
annoying to support anything that's per
car specific
comma's not that interested in doing
because it's not the highest leverage
thing we can do right
like we have a limited amount of
resources i'd much rather apply those
resources to something that's generic
that we can apply across our entire
fleet than applying to something that
only targets certain cars
and then android auto every screen's a
different resolution
we really like a uniform experience that
we can apply across every car when we do
it because that's like the best use of
common engineering resources
um well comma three have traffic light
and sign detection
yes will comma two maybe like i said
with all features look if all i have to
do is like i'm not to put an
if statement in it says if comma 2 you
know make him buy the new one i'm not
trying to be a dick like that
um but if it does require some serious
extra effort to support it for the comma
2 it is only going to come to the 3.
it's also possible and we don't know
like this is something we won't know
until like we build it and start doing
the big data analytics on it
there's some traffic lights that you
can't see
in the comma 2's camera so the comma 3
has a fisheye camera and
you can see them all
um would i ever allow tesla to buy
common not anymore
uh i offered it to elon uh before the
com2 came out
do i have plans to go on on lex's
podcast i think we did one recently
enough
um are you planning supporting the
commentary for longer than the two
well so the two was kind of the end
combination of a platform right like
you can say that the two has been
supported now for basically four years
uh so do we plan on supporting the three
it's gonna be kind of like the
the you know how long ago did we sell
eon gold right like
when the three iteratively gets upgraded
it's not like
it's all gonna be on the same platform
so the support will all stay
um there's big differences between the
two platform and the three platform
so it's why it's advantageous for us to
drop the two platform but like i said we
promise at least a year of support
and if it's easy we'll keep supporting
it right
it's only we're also going to look in a
year and see what our network looks like
right
if in a year our network is 90 comma
threes and 10
comma twos then we're gonna put all the
resources into the comma three and we're
gonna that's that's it for the comma two
support
if our network is 50 50 and we're still
selling common twos by the way and if
people buy the comma two we'll make more
um i'm happy to uh
you know like the comma three costs a
lot more
but our profits aren't really higher
right like the commentary costs a [ __ ]
ton of money to make
those [ __ ] sensors cost thirty
dollars of sensor
and that's just for the sensor never
mind the whole camera around it you need
a lens
you need to you need a cable you need to
focus it so you know when all said and
done like the cameras are
expensive right you know how much the
comma 2 cameras cost
10 bucks right 10 bucks for the front
one and like
five bucks for the back one i'm talking
15 bucks both cameras in the combat 2
cost less than half a single camera in
the comment three
so you know i'm happy to keep selling
them both combat2 is a much higher
margin product
than the common three percent wise
um we make obviously more profit on each
three but the gross margin on the two is
higher
uh yeah well so absolutely
we don't sell on safety all we say is
that our goal at common with safety is
to make sure that we don't make driving
less safe than driving without a car
right we're not we very much do not want
to make things less safe
more safe is just gravy right like our
goal is on par
i mean our goal is as safe as possible
but like our target is on par
is the company making any money yeah i
showed this off in comic-con
uh yeah we are we are profitable the
majority of our funding has come from
device sales not from investors
um how quickly do we start working on
the con before nobody has worked at all
on the con before
i swear i just walked you around the
office no one's even given thought to it
people you know we've given thoughts
like things we want to upgrade on the
comma 3 and we are going to
hopefully slowly upgrade them over time
but a lot of these things are not really
things that are going to change the
experience
the biggest thing is we have to figure
out how to make these devices cheaper
the comma 3 costs us a ton of money to
make
um who are our investors at the moment
a16z
a16z we did two rounds uh
google left on crunchbase bro are the
green hoodies for sale i don't think
anymore i think they were event
exclusive
um if you beg alex and offer a lot of
money maybe
uh how bad are nvidia sales people
nvidia's a sad case and they just said
they're gonna lose
nvidia has flushed down the toilet
their future of ai and their future of
automotive
uh by a crazy over-the-top
like kind of or really a really a really
like bad pricing structure and a really
bad like
like they're just like they're just
they're just trying to screw over their
consumers it seems like right like
there's no reason to say like
we prohibit the use of this thing for
this application
contractually like ew
um should you watch the replay of comic
con yeah it's awesome
um so yeah we're committed to qualcomm
for the future uh i think all future
common devices are gonna have qualcomm
chips in them
um eventually maybe qualcomm will reach
out and be easy to work with
a qualcomm in some ways is easier to
work with nvidia because
uh if you want to buy qualcomm chips you
can buy these from multiple
you can buy psalms from like 10
different companies
you can buy the chips in the chinese
marketplaces with nvidia they're the
only ones who make the som and the chips
are not available in the
chinese marketplaces so like why are we
using video we can't we can't and i
regret the six months we wasted uh you
know some guy from nvidia reached out
and like he's like oh yeah you know he
heard that like was kind of mistreated
by nvidia
uh we want to like you know uh we want
to have a phone call to discuss this and
i'm like they're a thousand dollars and
the guy never replied
like so you know nvidia doesn't care um
and they're throwing away their future
in automotive it's so sad
yeah partner with mercedes that's the
future that's the future in video
that's ice bro um
realistically what cost reduction do we
think we can get on the comma three
uh like i said it's costing us a lot now
to make these devices
we are profitable but not we are making
money on each device but not nearly as
much as i would like
um i think we could maybe make them for
50 cheaper when all said and done
and no the prices aren't going to go
down the margins are going to go up
uh in fact we probably will raise the
prices a bit too
as we start to launch these features
right so what we've always done at comma
is we
start it low and raise it slowly over
time as as
the software provides more and more
value how the vip gen session go good
it's interesting conversations
ah crazy that everyone kept the comment
through her secret so long yeah addition
to the epoch people too
um make cheap comma threes is the
primary goal right now
what's up oh you want to know what hey i
showed them a little but
you guys here at the red pandas yep hi
everybody
so that's
the board and also you can see we have
these golden
pads this is gpios for those who want to
do
something interesting maybe to
to make their own device
use them for anything uh they plug right
into your
so uh this just plugs right into your
your commentary expansion port
uh they come in these beautiful little
red cases uh for sale right now
when we'll ship them probably pretty
soon we're gonna do the tesla yeah i
think
close closer to two weeks than today
eight weeks
very cool oh yeah they seem to be
working and we got
yeah and hardware support for sbi
iac uart oh on on
output of 12 volts 5 volts and 3 and 3.
so pretty everything
awesome abc also those
we gotta we gotta post a pit out
somewhere
post a little uh pdf yeah a little
nervous
uh yeah uh red pet is nice
the latest in the panda lineup
eventually all comma hardware
is going to move to uh to this but not
too many cars have canfd yet but we like
canfd
we like can fd a lot more than uh
then flex right because it's reasonable
cool yep scraped up
red panda dope
uh what's our plan on getting
commentaries less expensive to make
give you all guys an lcd instead of oled
you know how much i'm paying for them
damn oleds
now the gold's nice steel it's nice um
uh is something cheaper for the customer
planned or is it just gonna be getting
more and more expensive
uh more expensive but more and more
capable right so so it's a it's a
trade-off of cost for capability right
and like we keep the old product and the
old price around
so if you want to buy a comma two it's
the same price i don't think we're gonna
raise the comma two's price again i
think that's probably the price for the
rest of the life
uh we're paying more for the oled on the
comma three than we paid for the entire
lay eco phone in the comma two
yeah i'm curious about big model two we
haven't seen big improvements from it a
lot of the things that we think big
model are gonna improve
actually comes from data bugs how many
active users are there right now
i have like i said what 3 500 weeklies
their good ips screen is okay try i'm
not shipping a shitty screen trust me
the screen will be good i'm never
i never want the device like slip
qualitatively we're all about quality
here
you know when we first started out we
got a sign that said quality and the
sign was a little ripped and we were
like the irony we can't even make a
quality sign right
the company's moved a lot in the last uh
in the last
three four years um yeah you can play
kanye's new album
bumping three watt speaker still needs a
little bit of tuning
the sound out of the box is not perfect
but it's not hardware it's software
tuning speakers is tricky and then like
there's all this like dsp frequency crap
we'll get it
it's pretty good it's pretty good it's
not bad but um
it's not hardware it's software uh
linux sound also so the commentary is
linux it's not android
and like in almost every way um
you know linux is better than android
but linux sound is a nightmare
uh i have plans with partnering up
people always use this word partnering
can you define it for me
uh is there a notable development in the
temperature yeah the comma 3 in the
stress test
runs at like 60 degrees celsius the
comma 2 in the stress test runs at 90.
with the cpu at full tilt it's 30
degrees celsius less on the cpu course
do we have dedicated ux designers yes uh
do we hire ml engineers without hardcore
cv experience absolutely uh we think of
ml engineering a lot more of an
infrastructure problem so if you have
like big data and like
uh like like experience with big data
experience with
it's really infrastructure uh we're
happy to hire you uh i don't care if you
know like
the latest and like winnigrad
convolutions or whatever
um we're only here to talk about comma
this is the comma channel
uh spotify or some kind of media stuff
no we thought about this you know the
original eon had spotify
um but what happens
people are very happy with the media
solution on their phone people are
generally happy with the navigation
solution on their phone too
the problem is with the navigation
solution on their phone there's no way
we can integrate
uh navigate an open pilot into that uh
with music
use your phone how much is the c3
underclocked quite a bit
similar to the c2 uh
what's the difference between oled and
lcd screens google that
tell you more about navigation uh i
think i think
i think are in a blog post
does the comment three way more than the
comma two no it's lighter a little bit
lighter it's not that much lighter
our plans were to make it a good bit
lighter and then like things kind of
crept up so they're
uh but they're lighter than the two but
just a little uh it does help though
that like the comma two
has this absolutely ridiculous looking
mount
um the the common two has the comma
three is not like that
i don't i don't have one someone took my
commentary
um if you guys want to see the pictures
just look on the website
why does the commentary need so much
storage because files are big
can you use dash cam absolutely it is a
dash cam
uh do the folks at research also publish
stuff everyone's welcome to
it's just like we've published a few
things mostly a question of like time
it takes a lot of time to put those pdfs
together check out comma 2k19
original paper learning a driving
simulator uh
we wrote that the blog post on the
antenna lateral was kind of uh
really nice oh thank you
we found a dirty-ish pre-polished
old comma three that's pretty nice still
pretty nice
okay random comma three sitting in a
deep's office
um yeah but you can see that the uh the
the mount in the comma three is not um
you know
stupid looking sorry comma two owners
we put a comma two up on the wall with
the comma threes and we made fun of it
can i summarize the difference between
the comma three and the comma 2 features
we'll just like look at them first off
two cameras second off much better
cameras third off
two usb ports fourth off big driver
monitoring camera instead of little
driver monitoring camera
fourth off it's not like stupid and big
and have these big plastic ears on it
just all screen pretty much uh
those are most of the benefits of the
360 obviously you can see out here it
can see out here it can see actually out
in every direction because 360 is all
the degrees
uh the 845 gpu so the flop number is
only like 50
more but you see in practice it's like
twice as good
because the limit is actually not the
alus it's the memory fetch pipeline
i've looked a lot into this i've looked
a lot into this so the 845 gpu is really
about twice as good as the gpu and the
a20
the dsp is a ton better uh we've barely
even tapped that
um on the on the three uh i think we're
using like twelve percent of the gpu on
our dsp on here and we use like two
percent
here it's nothing do i think it'll stop
on red lights absolutely
uh i will say with almost
put it this way one of two things is
going to happen either com is going to
go
out of business or the comma three's
gonna stop at red lights
um i'm hoping for the latter nah it's
gonna be the latter it's gonna be the
latter we're
we're somewhat close on red lights the
the i there is no way in hell i can
imagine a world where comma solves red
lights and it doesn't come to the comma
3.
the comma 3 hardware is definitely
capable of doing red lights it's unclear
about the comma 2 hardware
will it keep going on green lights
absolutely i'm never shipping stopping
on green lights
uh uh his contractors don't have stock
uh stocks only for full-time place um
no interns get stock either does that
have a touchscreen of course
uh yeah we switched to pi torch tesla
beta versus comma three
i mean tesla slogans look at this crazy
feature our slogans make driving chill
that's the difference
stop signs and red lights will come at
the exact same time although
red lights it will auto resume stop
signs it will stay stopped and you'll
have to either hit the gas or tap the
button to resume
actually i think it'll only be the gas i
think at a stop sign you're going to
have to tap the gas to resume it's not
going to auto go at a stop sign but it
will auto go when a red light turns
green
um how does it handle yellow lights does
it speed up or stop early we are going
to leave that to whatever the human
policy is
um whatever humans do depends
um if you just saw the light turn yellow
and you're close go for it if
not don't go for it right um and if you
don't like it obviously you step on the
break
it's level two uh i don't know super
chat is
planning on self-driving cars with only
cameras oh the outputs all it'd be so
much more rich if we had lighter no we'd
spend our like calibrating lidars
the update on voacc progress now we're
just talking about commentaries here
nice comma logo on the front of casing
thank you
thank you um if the lens gets much
should you clean it yeah we ship them
with microfiber cloths
i wish i had one of those microphone
cloths now um i'm gonna run it here give
me a microphone o'clock
uh so we could we could clean it they
come with a little microfiber cloth
nice thinking of hiring any cone guys
there is
no opening is a comma for cone guys i'm
sorry what will you use the extra
processing power for
nav more models all that stuff um
did you rent did you buy no you guys did
it it's all community
uh will german cars be supportive not
flex-ray probably not microfiber short
is real no we got some microfibers
we're gonna ship with them um so if you
bought all three it'd be over four
thousand dollars so much for free
software
the software is free but the software if
if you bought every version of open
pilot right when it came out it still
would have cost you zero dollars
if you bought hardware well yeah it
costs you money you do understand linux
doesn't run on free either you have to
buy a box to run the linux on
right um you can run open pilot on a pc
if you want to like you actually don't
have to buy anything from comma
it's gonna be a pain in the ass right
like a lot of the stuff we built was
just to kind of make our lives easier
why is having an old screen so important
it's like not
but like they're really nice i just
wanted to be really nice big model on
common three yeah big models coming to
common three
big model might come to comma two
probably will um
but we haven't seen advantages yet from
big model
by partnering i mean working with a
company that can mass produce oled
screens
wait that doesn't sound like partnering
that sounds like a purchase order
yes i would love to buy oleds from
samsung i think we sent them an email
they probably said
do you want to buy a million otherwise
[ __ ] off right that's not partnering
like i hate this word it's like vague
it's like hooking up yo i hooked up with
her last night well did you make out or
did you
you know stop with that stupid word
um yes would we like to buy the oleds
directly from samsung
absolutely um is your back gonna stop
hurting if you buy comma three i did
this is this is not an fda approved
medical device
any reason to not use the 888 yeah
because the drivers aren't there
the 845 is like the only one you can
really get linux support for
um there's no 8088 dev kits yet there
are 865 dev kits but there's no good
linux for it right we're going to be on
the a45 platform for years
for years i don't see us changing the
processor for a while
um the biggest limitation i mean the
combat 2 had ran into some processor
limitations
but the biggest limitation with the
comma 2 and the biggest upgrade from the
comic
two to the three is not the processor
it's the cameras
uh we really started to run into
limitations of this camera
a lot of the reason so like you know
when you want to stop for a stopped card
or red light and you're going too fast
and the combat 2 doesn't see it until
the last minute
that's a camera limitation uh the three
doesn't have that limitation
because this camera has both double the
resolution
and half the field of view so that's
effectively 4x the resolution so we can
see cars hypothetically up to 4x that
the distance
uh why not 4k because lenses um these
lenses can't resolve 4k
getting a lens that can resolve 4k is
actually really expensive
um these lenses can resolve 1080p 484
4k lenses you're talking like slr style
lenses that are going to cost hundreds
and hundreds of dollars
i have not seen a lens this size that
can actually resolve
4k resolution um so if your lens can't
resolve the full resolution you have to
make a trade off
do you want more pixels on the image
sensor or do you want larger pixels and
i'll make the trade off every day for
larger pixels
ah so yeah that's why um
look like this this camera has a 16
megapixel sensor
these cameras have two megapixel sensors
the picture from this camera looks
way better than the picture from this
camera and it's through the lens
and do the pixel size and due to the you
know just the
the all the quantum efficiency on these
sensors like through the roof
um ar 0231 if you want to look it up
uh is it from a sony phone nah
um no it's it's custom uh
the the panel is used on a phone but the
screen is not uh you see that it doesn't
have any uh
phony holes do they have carl zeiss
lenses i do not believe so
they're good lenses though they can
resolve so we did the test if you want
to test how good a lens is
we did the uh test with uh alternating
white and black lines
you know and then make sure we could
actually resolve
perfectly uh the lens um
like the lens can actually like each
pixel can actually land on a line and
there's not too much power
are we using all the cameras for the
driving model nope right now
at launch we're using the little one um
we will see them though we can't really
use the cameras until we gather the data
so the model that we're shipping with
the comma three is the joint model with
the comma two we just did a little bit
of
augmentation to make it compatible with
comma three as well and i posted
yesterday on discord the
results of the comma three are actually
better than the results of the comma two
uh the model performs better on the
comma three data already just because
you know it's not blurry
uh nav data will be streamed live over
comma prime uh will they do good and
rain and snow as good as the two
probably better uh ir headlights and
lamp posts kill light pollution
i don't know about that what about the
people on the road uh will black friday
be more expensive
um
[Music]
i don't know black friday disc
i'm not even thinking that far ahead i
don't think holding a discount probably
not it's probably too no maybe we'll see
um will the comma 3 os ever be rebased
on a newer version of ubuntu yeah
probably
uh if we at the office change so we went
in the office from 1604 to 2004.
if we go in the office to like 2404 then
we'll upgrade the version
um it's not like uh stupid uh android
which you can never upgrade
oh you wanna upgrade the android eight
oh yeah that's going to be a multi-month
project
if we want to upgrade the user space in
ubuntu i think that's comfortably uh
let me put it this way it took about two
weeks to move the whole office from 1604
to 2004. in fact
the first comma threes had 1604 so uh we
already did it once we'll do it again
um we'll double the price when you build
it yeah that sounds good
uh can comma take monero as payment soon
let's
uh no uh i don't trust miners
i don't know i'll take monero maybe you
don't like bitcoins and ethereums
um no if drug markets use it we don't
comma's legitimate operation
uh two cameras viewing the road on the
common three you can see them there is
little camera and there is big camera
this is the f camera this is the e
camera this is the d
camera um don't ask why
[Music]
remote work no comma doesn't do remote
work um
you can work in europe uh we have a
rotterdam office and we have a us
office but we have a zero remote policy
um
you know it's just how it works for us
what's left to do
before open pilot 1.0 whole list of
things
uh eta new blog post on nav whenever
wilm does it
i don't know i think he was hired for
already things at first but he did
mention doing it
uh any plans on moving to the bay zero
we got out of there
uh probably going to stay here i don't
know we'll see
right now is cool i haven't actually
been i haven't been to the rotterdam
office yet because it started after
kovid
and uh i left the country once to go to
mexico and even that was kind of
stressful so i haven't left america much
um external gpu yes very possibly
um so if we do just if we do realize
that the
model size is the limiting factor and we
can't run
uh the we can do better with a larger
model than what can run on the comma
three
the comma three is capable of streaming
its entire censorium out of this usb
port which is a super important feature
so we could potentially ship a comma
compute which is like a 30 90 in a
little box
that uh plugs into here and then like
does the model uh over there
and sends it back and you can totally do
this with timings none of that stuff's a
problem
we've tested this already so yeah it's
if the comma three is
expandable if we do decide that the size
of the model becomes a limiting factor
uh yeah you can't do that on the two
there's another downside to the two
uh again you're gonna have to tell me
what partnering means and we don't hire
any biz dev
uh will the ford machi be can fd
community a can of d is canfd you can
already buy a red panda and plug it into
here and it works
or it will work in openpod08 um we
already have our prius driving around
with a comma 3 and a red panda
so again this expansion port tons of
flexibility say you need both can fd
and a model computer we could do that
too just put a hub in there
um so no they're not from a sony phone i
told you that
i mean might sony have used it i don't
know it's a samsung oled panel
uh it's been used in a few phones
um i don't know what partnering means
was there ever a fan and the three
three there's a fan yeah there's a fan
in here there's a fan
uh the fan is for the most part pretty
quiet you will hear it if you left it
out in the hot sun it orders up at the
beginning kind of like the gaming laptop
uh similar to the com2 uh will c2 do
will c3 do navigation on open pilot
absolutely
uh any plans of making common prime more
affordable no prices are going to go up
we lose money on comma prime we lose
money i'm telling you
uh maybe the only thing we were
considering is maybe we'll make it 16
a month if you bring your own sim card
tethering will not be supported though
in order for you to be able to buy this
plan
you have to have a dedicated sim card
for the device
um
little driver monitoring camera let me
go over here driver modern camera be
using the driving models in the future
yeah
it will hopefully uh ssd controller
overheating
uh we tested this it's pretty good um
we don't maybe if we ran it like full
tilt for a long time
but we don't so um we track this too
give you a bulleted list why buy a c3
because you own a c2
uh we were joking about this in the
meeting this morning about like
making fun of how companies do this like
look i'm not going to convince you man
if you don't want to buy it don't buy it
uh if you do want to buy it buy it why
why should you buy a comma 3 because you
want a comma 3. why shouldn't you buy a
comma 3 because you don't want a comma
3.
um highest temperature comet three can
withstand so what i can say about this
is uh first off these things have been
in the melting
i mean i i've landed 30 minutes east and
it gets up that's like 95 out there
it's it's it's it's scorching i got once
back in the car and it said 118
on the hyundai thing uh and my three
survive fine
um we've tested these at 85 celsius in
an oven
for 24 hours and they don't break so uh
that's what i can say about heat
heat's always gonna be a problem also
like the thermal policy takes
is gonna take some big data to really
refine and make good like it took us a
bit on the comma two when the comma two
first came out when summer hit
everyone was complaining about the comma
two's uh overheating
and it was bad um but it wasn't it's not
hardware it's software
uh so we fixed that uh is the sonata the
comma flagship yeah i mean it's in the
pictures right
um can i make a ten thousand dollar
version that's water cooled with a full
size 3090
well i mean what you'll be able to do is
you'll just be able to plug a 30 90 into
here
uh so yeah no need to uh
make a device that has it integrated
does it still disengage at 65c and we
maybe update i don't know well
again all this stuff's got to be tweaked
uh cool on the heat yeah
the thermal solution in the common three
is much more capable than the one and
the two because the heatsink's touching
the processor
right in the comma two the processor
actually faces the screen
and that's just how cell phones are
because you can't jump into the user's
hand the only place you can dump heat is
into the screen on a cell phone
but the comma three is not like that the
comma three the processor faces that way
right onto the heatsink with the fan
that's good
uh well ethernet can be supported
someone can make an adapter again that's
the beauty of this
expansion uh why not white molding for
the case i'm not sure black and white
matters that much i think most of the
heat's in the infrared spectrum
not 100 on that uh black's nicer color
than white how about that
um a45 has internal gpu that's true
uh why use such a high-res screen
because it's beautiful we'll see if we
do auto lane
just a stupid feature guys
uh why usb for external gpu and not
thunderbolt 3. the
qualcomm chip does not support
thunderbolt 3.
um can you mirror your common three
screen to another screen yes this is a
display port as well
um this is a displayport 1.2 connector
there's a little switch inside that
switches so
if you plug this into a monitor uh it
won't work because
the software is janky but if you fix the
software the hardware supports it
um will comets redo u-turns or even
stupider than auto lane change
make your own u-turn um
does it read speed limits who knows it's
a model who knows what it does i never
taught it to but it learned some things
on 90 degree turns oh really we're
really in the stupid feature land today
you don't want it be in a car doing an
autonomous 90 degree turn you're like
please don't ever do that again
um will it do it yeah it probably will
in fact have you seen the comma 2 can do
90 degree turns watch some videos
there's a whole bunch of toyotas making
90 degree turns with the comma 2.
uh did i change the sound effects no
it's the same sound effects if you want
them changed
submit a pull request if someone makes
nice sound effects i will merge them
if someone makes nice sound effects and
shows that they can continually improve
open pilot we'll even hire you
we'll comment fly maybe
um
what are the specs of the device google
how many we sell
we sell it
one one since this game started
uh
it'll fly off the shelves does comma
three come with a cup holder
uh oh my god we're already past an hour
on this no
all right now we're getting stupid
questions the questions got stupid
all right any more good questions
i don't want to leave people with good
questions hanging out try to google it
comma dot ai go to the thing uh what i
think the current best vehicle is
personally i think it's the sonata uh
it's not a longitudinal stock as well
maybe i just think that because calm's
longitudinal needs a bit of love
um the sonata lateral is is
really keyed in really dialed in um
any regulatory risks we've been in
contact with regulatory agencies
like i mean again we don't sell safety
but
uh the data is pretty promising so
there's that that's always nice
um how's the common three powered right
here it also has super capacitors in it
so if you pull the power you get like
five seconds of emergency power that we
can use to alert the user that we can
use to write logs
we only sold three we sold a lot more
than three we made more than three
hundred thousand dollars and we sold
more comma threes in the last three days
than we did comma twos for the whole
first week
and that's not dollars that's in units
so in dollars
um any theft protection we're not an
insurance company work with your
insurance company if you want that
protection
uh what cars do i wish the community
would jump in to help support
encrypted toyotas you guys can do it i
believe in you
um if someone ships flex ray
if someone ships good flex right i will
chill for you um there's a
guy in discord who made a adapter to get
the
honda accord that uses serial uh they
did a serial to can converter and we
gave them a channel on discord and
they're selling these things
so if you support a car in a safe way
it's very important that it's safe but
if you do it a safe way
uh yeah we'd love to chill for your
thing and you know so uh yeah flex rate
community let's go
um you do not have to order a new
harness nope it's the identical harness
and we give you all the wires you're
gonna need uh to connect the comma three
the comma three uses a right angle wire
that like sits in here like this
it's super nice um
does it use the modem inside the 845 soc
unfortunately not
uh the som doesn't come with a modem so
we have an additional cocktail modem on
there
i told you this device was expensive
part of the reasons it costs a lot to
make i'd love to use the 845 soc but
good luck getting that from qualcomm
uh can you buy the right angle wire
separate i believe so
um i don't know if we put it up yet but
we are certainly going to put it up and
they're going to be 20
um they're not up yet but i think we'll
do that pretty soon
it's our main bottleneck right now bugs
uh why is auto lane change stupid
we have auto lane change it's just the
the user
does the lane change i have not liked
like i don't like being in a car
when it makes a maneuver that i don't
expect um
it's doable i think auto lane change is
less stupid than some other features
but i think features like slow down for
turns automatic
highway interchanges red lights and stop
signs are much better features
now to be fair i used to say this about
red lights and stop signs
five years ago i was making fun of red
lights and stop signs
because five years ago like we couldn't
take every turn on the highway
now it's time to stop making fun of red
lights and stop signs and you know what
in five years i'll stop making fun of 90
degree turns on auto lane change
but i think those are like further out
and more gimmicky than you think
uh i think the core things that you want
are things that don't
ever have the car perform in a like the
thing about an auto lane change is
you don't actually have to do a lane
change right so it's it's clearly very
much just a feature you do have to stop
at a red light so the fact that we don't
stop at a red light is not great
um and that's why i'm much more excited
about like red lights and stop signs
than i am about auto lane change
um any chance of comma prime for a lower
price bring your own network yes i think
we're going to make it 16
a month uh when we refactor the billing
code
uh i'm um yeah i'm that's not bad of you
i think that'll probably be out if you
buy a comma three right now your three
free months prime will be included
and then i think by the time the three
months are over we'll be able to lower
the
you do not buy a sim from us plan to uh
16.
i think the future harness won't be
needed no i think the same harness
community forever i know i can't wait
for red lights and stop signs either i'm
very excited about that feature i'm even
more excited for slow down
slow down for turns slow down for turns
slow down returns means a lot more than
turns
slow down returns means that if you have
the cruise control set at 65 and you're
in the city
it's not going to go 65 it's gonna go a
reasonable speed
um you know anytime we're doing things
also that involve more braking i always
feel better about more braking right
because brakes are safe
um slow down for turns hype slow down
for turns hype yeah but it's not just
turns like
i shouldn't say turns basically here
here's what i want you to think of when
i say slow down insurance
imagine you're in an exit lane of the
highway there's no battery in the
country
uh imagine being in the exit lane of a
highway
automatically slowing down for the exit
and then being on surface streets
without ever pushing the cruise control
thing down you'll be able to
keep the cruise control thing at 65 but
if you're on surface streets it'll only
go 25 or 30.
um yeah so you're just in the exit lane
you can do the auto lane change i mean
we call it auto lane change right like
i'm sorry you have to tap the wheel but
like you know again i think it feels
better
i think it feels better to like it's a
way of
it's a language for talking to the car
it's like make me a lane change right
um when is end of life for the comma two
software support ends in one year
so uh one year uh from when the common
three was announced
why can we optimize your low g forces
when driving we do uh we absolutely do
we're the mpc code
um are you missing data or time
always time not data definitely not data
i have too much data i mean we're
missing comment three data we do need
some comma three data
uh the common three data we're excited
about getting i have too much comma 2
data we're throwing a lot of it away
um can you start your three month prime
title at a time no
uh min support length for the comma 3.
look
guys we're a small company um
i mean our minimum support our absolute
minimum is a year but it's going to be a
lot longer than a year it's
this is the new platform right so if you
think about when you bought an eon gold
and eon gold is the same platform as
this neon gold and a black panda
so eon gold in a black panda was almost
two years ago so
that's a comfortable support time it'll
i mean if you go back all the way to the
eon that's a year before that if you go
back all the way
to the to the neo it's like a year
before that's like four years
this platform's gonna be supportive a
long time well navigation be on c2 no
navigation's never coming to c2
um maybe fork can try to do it we tried
a little it was just a pain it's a pain
to make it all work with the stupid uh
uh android level two forever
is there a battery in the comma three
there's a very very tiny battery
uh in both the comma three and the comma
two used for the real-time clock
so that when you lose power you don't
lose time you don't lose the date
uh but otherwise no no battery
uh well the high data rate of c3 data
make it harder to get back uh
connected to wi-fi um how is it in stop
and go traffic
good um where do people sell their use
comma twos you can check on discord
uh there's a for sale channel now
actually if you're looking to buy a used
coma too
this is probably the exact time to buy
them
um have we delivered any comment threes
yet no the first ship out on thursday
slow down on curve soon soon soon um
can you use nav on c3 and asia i believe
so i think willem will clarify this
i know he uses it in europe uh so
i don't know i haven't tried it in asia
but yeah i think for sure
maybe depends where in asia too i know
china has a lot of like weird rules
around
mapping um does kama own any other
companies
no what do you mean own any other
companies like do we have like another
brand we sell things under no
i'm like okay facebook owns oculus but
oculus is just facebook right it's
interesting
um any way to invest in comment not
right now um maybe someday
look like if someone sends me a pitch
occasionally people will reach out to
invest in comma and i like like them i
like like them as people
and i'm like yeah if we ever looking for
money you know that's that's who gets to
invest
uh a lot of people reach out and they're
like i'm a banker
and i want to invest in you so i can
diversify my portfolio
and i'm like oh boomer phi
um camera-based longitudinal control
absolutely coming soon
uh no but sometimes people invest and
they're just like cool people like we
get a bunch of people who are like yo i
made a lot of money off tesla
uh i want to put some of my gains into
something and i'm like ah
uh if we do any investment yeah you're
the kind of person i want to let in
uh you know people who like someone who
invested in tesla is the kind of person
who's like they're like
betting on a good future and like that's
who we want right we don't want the kind
of people who are like
well i manage my portfolio to headphones
and index funds and lots of different
weird funds and mutual funds and we
trade options and we trade all this
weird stuff and it's
it's not even that weird it's boomer fry
um
yeah sometimes we get cool crypto people
too i like when like crypto people are
like yo man
i made a lot of money in heath uh
i'm interested in that too
boomers go burn no no oh yes yes hoy
this is the united states fed
we just printed four trillion dollars
and we'd like to offer you some in
exchange for a piece of your soul
do you want some fake money in exchange
for a piece of your soul
um no um
what if you make money on gamestop yeah
you know
no we're not really looking for an
investment um what will the limitations
of the comma three be
there's no obvious limitations right now
uh so we don't know
we really don't know like the comma two
you know it was clear that like it
didn't support
yes the commentaries will stop on red
lights eventually i promise you that
or common we'll go out of business one
of those two things will happen first
[Music]
um a lot of money flipping bricks can i
invest why are you gonna show up with
your
will your dollar bills be covered in
cocaine
uh what's the next feature we'll bring
to the comma 3. uh
navigate on open pilot is going to be
the huge feature and that's like the
prices go up kind of feature
um can you find comma 3 can you want the
specs
here i'll paste you a link
slow down on a curve yeah hopefully
that'll come to both i i will try to
shift the still down on curve on comma 2
as well
um but the you know stopping for faraway
car is going to be a lot better when we
start to get data back